[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
on november 17 2012 two fishermen took
their modest boat out on the pacific
ocean from a small mexican port for a
day trip
it was the first time that salvador
alvarenga and ezekiel cordoba had worked
together
overtaken by a violent storm
they were able to send out one distress
signal before their radio gps and
outboard motor died
driven into the open sea they drifted
for weeks tormented by thirst eating
fish turtles and sea birds they caught
with their bare hands
from time to time a thunderstorm would
provide a little fresh water that they
caught in plastic bottles and in an oil
drum they had retrieved from the sea
in this small open boat with no
protection from the sun or cold they
spent a great deal of time huddled
together in the insulated fish box that
was about the size of a refrigerator
gradually sickened by the diet cordoba
stopped eating and he died after 10
weeks
though desperately lonely alvarenga
refused to give up
he often prayed and said that if god
would spare him he'd be a better man and
more dedicated as a father
then on january 30 2014
alvaranga's tattered boat washed up on
the eben atoll in the southernmost tip
of the marshall islands
6 000 miles from where he had started
adrift for 438 days jose salvador
alvarenga holds the record for the
longest solo survival at sea
can you imagine that there's a picture
of him there a few days after he had
been rescued and they had actually
gotten him where he could get up on his
feet again when he first washed his
shore on that island i've been to the
marshall islands i've been to uh
manjaro
um and that's when he's landing there
he just started walking again when he
first landed he had to crawl because he
hadn't stood
and
barely stood i should say in a year
and an incredible story of someone
surviving by themselves catching
rainwater turtles he'd grab sharks out
of the water he'd grab the little fish
he'd eat the barnacles off the bottom of
the boat it's just an amazing amazing
story but one thing that i didn't share
that was in the it's not in the amazing
fact i just read
is that
his friend ezekiel cordoba was a
born-again christian alvarenga was not
he was kind of against church he
believed in god but
and before he died alvarenga a cordoba
ramble rather
worked on his friend's heart and
solvent his heart he ended up turning to
god
and
redeemed his life he went back home and
became a good father and gave up his
wild partying ways and it really was a
conversion experience for him
that's an amazing so he was rescued in
more than one more than one way
and i think we've got an offer that
when there's a verse friends i always
like to put in a bible verse that goes
along with our fact psalm 107 verse 23
and 24
those who go down to the sea in the
ships who do business on the great
waters
they see the works of the lord and his
wonders in the deep
well he sure got to see the wonders of
the deep for quite a period of time it
is amazing story of just determination
uh doubtless his prayers made a
difference because he was praying near
the end he realized that his only help
was god
and yet for him to survive that long not
only just living on whatever he could
find the fish and drinking the rain
water but just being by himself in the
middle of the ocean for so long uh you
would think you know somebody would give
up but he just refused to give up yeah
and you know i could go on it's quite a
story but there were about 20 times that
tankers went by and he would wave and
they'd wave back they just thought he
was out fishing he was trying to get
rescued and he'd see planes fly over and
tankers go by and they just didn't stop
and so then you get real discouraged for
a while sure absolutely well we do have
a free offer pass today that talks about
a much more important rescue and that is
called rescue from certain deaths saved
from certain death that is the free
offer and it talks about salvation i
mean whatever happens here on this earth
if we are saved from eternal destruction
we have hope we have peace and so that's
the free offer how can we have the
assurance of salvation it's called save
from certain dev to receive it all you
need to do is call the resource number
that's 800-835-6747
and ask for offer number 109
again the number to call is 800-835-6747
and you can ask for the gift it's called
save from certain death we'll be happy
to send it to anyone in north america if
you're outside of north america we
encourage you to go to the amazing facts
website just
amazingfacts.org and you can actually
read the lesson there for free you can
enroll in the free amazing facts online
course and i know many folks have been
blessed by going through the series of
lessons and that's all available at
amazingfacts.org
well pastor doug we've got some folks
who've called in with their bible
questions if you have a bible related
question the number to call again is
800-463-7297
again that's
800-463-7297 that is the phone line to
our studio with your bible question our
first call of this evening is diane
listening in british columbia diane
welcome to the program
hey how are you
good thank you for calling
thank you yes i have a question i have a
friend who's just picking up the bible
and she's reading through the old
testament and she's really struggling
with all of god's violence that's talked
about in the old testament and it's
making her question how god can be love
and i'm just wondering where do i start
by helping her to see the love of god
when she's reading this
well one really important place to
director is the teachings of jesus he
said
if you've seen me you've seen the father
so she wants to understand something
about what god is like the god in the
old testament is the same god that you
see in jesus
and god is love this is what the
apostles saw the love and the compassion
of jesus
now you know in the old testament you're
often reading about god leading a nation
and those nations were often warring and
so god not wanting his people to be
annihilated they had to defend
themselves you know god does not
he does not want anyone to die the bible
tells us the lord does not want anyone
to perish
and in the book of ezekiel it says turn
eternity why will you die
god has no pleasure in the death of the
wicked but because of sin in the world
because there are sinful people
sometimes there was war and sometimes
there was violence and
and
i know some people passed a raw struggle
with just the idea of the sacrificial
system you know why would these innocent
animals die
it tells us something about the the
deadly nature of sin
and despite the violence and the war
that you do read about in the old
testament because talking about
different kingdoms you also get amazing
revelations of god's love his mercy his
long suffering with israel and his
protection i'm just thinking of children
in israel as they wandered through the
wilderness how god fed them with a
special food from heaven how he gave
them water from the rock how that god
forgave them time and time again from
their rebelliousness and throughout the
history of of israel you can see how
god's mercy was there
and how you forgave them yep amen
all right well thanks for your call
diane we've got lee listening in north
carolina
lee welcome to the program
oh hi pastors thank you so much for
taking my call my question is about
genesis um and the um actually the
sabbath chapter two in genesis right god
sanctified the day and then in exodus
you have the ten commandments where of
course
the you know sabbath is the fourth
my question is
how did god communicate to the jews
about the sabbath because noah wasn't a
jew
did he know about this habit did he keep
the sabbath how did god communicate back
before the actual laws
yeah you can find where pastor ross
might find the reference where it talks
about abraham now abraham's not a jew
you know abraham lived before they ever
went through the exodus and came to
mount sinai and the bible says abraham
kept my laws my statutes and my
judgments
and i don't remember if that's genesis
25 26 verse 5 okay
you want to read the whole verse there
yeah it says speaking of abraham he
obeyed my voice kept my charge my
commandments my statutes and my laws so
god had law
the bible tells us that god told
cain that sin was at the door when he
murdered his brother he was
that was clearly a sin and god told
joseph that
adultery would be a sin when potiphar's
wife tempted him and before the children
of israel got to mount sinai
the bread from heaven would rain down
six days a week but there'd be none on
the seventh day of the week and god said
this is the sabbath so i do believe when
noah was building the ark he took off
every sabbath day i don't think he
worked seven days a week
and
that they knew about that day of rest
man has always needed that rest
physically and as our quality time with
god that's why jesus said the sabbath
was made for man and the word there man
is it's not jew it's anthropos it means
humanity so god gave adam and eve the
sabbath back in the garden and they
passed it on faithful kept it those
unfaithful did not keep it as with the
other commandments you know we do have a
study guide that talks about that it's
called the last day of history and it
goes back to the history of the sabbath
and how that was established at creation
if you'd like to learn more about that
the number to call is 800 800-835-6747
and again you can ask for that free
offer it's called the last day of
history we'll be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks that's
800-835-6747
thanks for your call lee we've got uh
maya listening from north dakota
maya welcome to the program
thank you i appreciate you taking the
call
yes
and your question
okay so my question is i've been
studying ezekiel and at the end of
ezekiel
god takes him in a vision
and the angels measuring
is he
um the sanctuary on earth the heaven
sanctuary or the new jerusalem i'm
confused on what's going on at the end
of ezekiel
all right ezekiel is one of the four
apocalyptic prophets in the bible
meaning that god spoke to them in these
visions that were full of symbols and
not always to be taken literally
it's like when you get to revelation it
talks about a woman riding a beast with
seven heads well that's not real those
symbols
you know the woman represents a church
there it's a fallen church
in ezekiel the temple of god you know
the bible says what don't you know that
you are the temple of god is what paul
tells us and so when ezekiel is
measuring the temple
it's also there's a measuring of the
temple in revelation
that is referring back to ezekiel
and
it's talking about really a judgment of
god's people so all these things it's
talking about that beautiful temple in
ezekiel i think are in symbolic language
you there yeah yeah
yeah i am here
yeah because there there's no time in
history in jewish history or to the
present time
when that temple was physically built
first of all it was huge it's much
bigger than when they rebuilt the temple
and then you read about the river
and he says you know he he goes into
this river that's a mile long and and uh
a mile wide i should say
and he um
you know halfway in he's only up to his
thighs it's this huge river and then he
talks about the trees by the river
uh
continually bear fruit and their leaves
are for healing or for medicine well
that's taken from like revelation where
it says the leaves of the tree of life
are for the healing of the nation so a
lot of parallels between ezekiel
especially to the last chapters there
and revelation
they should probably be studied together
that's right so one might even
understand that is to uh be a symbolic
representation of the sanctuary in the
new earth in the new jerusalem that we
read about with the where the river is
flowing forth the river of life that
flows out yeah so there's some parallels
there in that study with the revelation
thanks for your call we've got caleb
listening in new york caleb welcome to
the program
hello pastor ross and pastor dog bashful
thank you so much for everything thank
you for calling thank you for picking up
yeah okay so i have a question for you
i've been worried about lately two
questions
i want to know if daniel 9 um daniel 11
has any correlation with what's going on
in russia right now
um
and my other question is is that i live
with one of my friends i have a lot of
friends that are christians
and
one time not too long ago i had a
discussion with my friends i didn't want
to give them
like he was very passionate about what
he believed but i felt like i didn't say
enough
to defend god
do you think god's gonna punish me for
that like because i i was just like i
told i said
told him the truth
but i wasn't
like very like forward about it like
yeah i was trying to hold an argument do
you think god's gonna punch you for that
i know exactly how you feel it's often
true and don't be discouraged
i think pastor ross will say that
there's probably times that he also has
thought after talking to someone about
the lord did i say the right thing did i
say enough did i miss an opportunity
that happens every day and you know if
we do
miss an opportunity or say something
wrong or don't say enough and sometimes
i've been ashamed at being ashamed of
you know sharing my faith
you ask god to forgive you and you move
on i mean even peter he boldly denied
christ and jesus forgave him
so
it's wrong we should pray that god helps
us to be faithful and courageous and
accurate and bold
even paul says pray for boldness because
sometimes we're intimidated to be timid
so but don't be discouraged if that
happens because i think every believer
has times where you think oh i wish i'd
done a better job
does that does that help caleb
oh now you asked about we never did
answer your question about daniel 11.
so um yeah i as far as daniel 11 and
what's happening now with the um the
conflict in the ukraine with russia
daniel 11 does cover the panorama of
history
from the time of
i guess it's from persia
two because babylon's already falled
when it be fallen so it covers the time
of history from persia
to the second coming
and so you have to get michael standing
up in the great final time of trouble in
the resurrection so it covers that time
span
i don't think there's any verses that
particularly mention
the battle that's going on in russia
with ukraine right now
it does talk about a number of wars but
i don't know of anything that would
allude to that in daniel 11.
yeah i think daniel especially daniel 9
11 you've got some time periods well
daniel 11 2. it's it's it's covering a
lot much larger time period than just a
few years about hundreds of years
thousands of years yeah that's been
reviewed within that within that chapter
kind of sweeping overview very quick
all right well thanks for your call
caleb we've got aaron listening in new
york erin welcome to the program
hello pastors thank you for taking my
call
thank you for calling
my question is
was noah and his three sons alive when
the power of people was being built
good question as far as noah
let me think i think after the flood he
still lives about 300 years so there's a
good chance
definitely his sons were still alive
because
shem
lived all the way to the time of abraham
and and you know the tower of babel had
been
uh considerably before that
so you go from it's not long after shem
that you end up with tara and heron
the parents of and brother of abraham
um
so
that doesn't necessarily mean that noah
had moved to the mesopotamian valley
where they built the tower so no one may
have been alive it's you know a lot of
people went down and they congregated
in um
the the land of sinar and that's where
they built the tower of babel
not everybody went noah may have stayed
somewhere in the foothills of ararat
where the ark settled
you know we do have a interesting
timeline that's available online it's a
website that amazing facts has bible
timeline
and if you were to look that up you
could actually page through it and you
can see the time of noah and then see
who was alive at the time and after that
when noah died and what was happening
it's just very informative so you might
want to take a look at that just go to
the amazing facts website
i think
history. history is that what it is yeah
i'm looking it up i think so okay yes we
have a number of websites friends if
you're wondering about that but this is
one that amazing facts put together that
is a great resource for people wanting
to study the bible get an idea of the
timelines biblehistory.com.org
and take a look at that a lot of good
information we've got lance listening
from texas lance welcome to the program
hi
um yeah
i know that ellen white he wrote a
prophecy and it pretty much said that um
there's going to be people alive from
her time
um
for the second coming of christ and if
that's the case
i guess then it must be really close
because um
we're the longest living person ever for
this modern era like 122 years so i
would like to know what's your take on
that
yeah well i i think i know what you're
talking about she made this one
statement in the book prophets and kings
where she talks about in the days of
queen esther
there was a law
that
all of god's people had to worship a
certain way or they were going to be
killed and she said you know there's
some living on the earth today that will
see those words fulfilled well there
already have been some people that have
lived to see
the words fulfilled that if you didn't
worship a certain way you'd be killed
they're people who are killed for their
faith all the time
you know if she was talking specifically
about uh the second coming there and the
final events
um
you know
she could have been talking in what you
call hyperbole and what i mean by that
is paul for instance said
um
the gospel has been preached in all the
world
well
he meant you know in the roman empire
um and so when she made a statement like
that if she's speaking in hyperbole she
means we're really near the end
you know something else to bear in mind
whenever you read the new testament and
you read for example paul he speaks of
being alive at the second coming of
christ it says we who are alive and
remain until the coming of the lord will
be caught up to meet them and the dead
in christ will rise first the prophet
envisioned never saw himself coming up
amongst those who are resurrected they
always see themselves amongst those who
are alive at the second coming of christ
that doesn't mean of course that you
know paul was wrong in saying that we
who are alive and remain unto the coming
of the lord but in vision he always saw
himself amongst those who were saved and
they called it the blessed hope
so you want to also bear that in mind as
you study through these different
prophetic passages of the bible
all right well thanks for call lance
we've got jerry listening in arizona
jerry welcome to the program
okay thank you pastors for taking my
call
uh so my question is in the gospels when
it refers to jesus's resurrection they
all say on the first day of the week
well i kind of discovered that um the
word weak is actually plural in greek
and it's the word for sabbath
which some people talk about referring
the beginning of the seven weeks to
pentecost
so i'm just wondering how this how
people can tie this to to worship
yeah well i it's there's no question
that jesus rose on what would be called
the first day of the week or sunday
because it says after the sabbath was
past
well what do you have after the sabbath
of the sabbath is the seventh day and
there's only seven days in a week after
the sabbath has passed all you've got
left is the first day
and so
jesus clearly rose very early in the
morning what you would call the first
day of the week now i don't think that's
that initiates sunday as a new day of
worship
there's no command in the bible anywhere
that we are to remember the first day or
sunday as the new sabbath or the lord's
day well if you use that argument pastor
you know there are some folks who say
we've got to on a sunday because that's
the day of the resurrection well what is
more important his death on calvary
which happened on a friday or his
resurrection on sunday
both are equally important without his
substitutionary death there'd be no hope
for a resurrection so just because those
are historical facts and those are the
days that those things occurred it
doesn't now somehow make it a new day of
worship yeah
yeah there's no reason to change the old
day god didn't make a mistake right
when ten commandments are written in
stone
and they're not multiple choice
you know we did mention a free offer a
little while ago it's called the last
day of history and again we want to
encourage those if you've never read
what the bible has to say about the
sabbath and the blessings of the sabbath
call and ask for that we'll be happy to
send it to you the number to call is
800-835-6747
and again you can ask for that free
offer it's called the last day in
history and if you have a bible question
we have a few lines open the number to
call is 800-463-7297
that's 800-463-7297
next caller that we have is
israel listening from washington israel
welcome to the program
how you doing uh how you doing doug
doing good thanks for calling
so my question is when god uh delivered
the israelites from slavery uh in egypt
uh took from my from my understanding he
basically took him on a crusade
wiping out every ungodly people
by killing every man woman and child
that was ungodly until they got to the
promised land
so if i choose to fight for my country
and let's say i go to war and i'm going
to have to kill
if these people are ungodly
um am i sinning by choosing to take that
route
uh
yeah i think it would be uh i think it
would be wrong you know jesus talks
about christians
um
not killing you know he came he said i
did not come to destroy men's lives but
to save them and just to be clear
the children of israel first of all in
the wilderness the only ones that they
fought against and annihilated were the
amalekites or they fought against they
didn't even annihilate them then there
were some pagan nations that were
uh bent on destroying israel
and so they were told to fight against
them
thus the interpersonal laws of the
christian are different from civil laws
god's laws or you know even national
laws god's laws regarding
civil things was under what they call a
theocracy
we are not under a theocracy that is led
by god we're under you know democracy
that's led by faulty humans
and so i think that a person needs to
think long and hard
about going to war and taking up arms to
shoot a person now
don't misunderstand i have tremendous
respect for
um young men and women two of them being
i've got a son and daughter that were in
the the service
i'm so thankful the freedoms that they
defend
but i think as a christian you need to
be very careful about
saying that i'm going to take up arms i
think if you're going to defend your
country try and find some area where you
can do it where
maybe you could help
save life or do it in a medical field or
something
well you know pastor like there are
examples you mentioned that israel at
the time they were being led by god the
cloud led them the pull of fire by night
prior to them going into war god would
communicate to moses and give them
instructions
in some cases it was a very um decisive
battle where the purpose was to remove
an ungodly group of people but there
were other times where god would
actually say no leave them alone or you
know save the woman and children so god
was actually leading and directing
israel part of the reason why israel
went into captivity for the 400 years
god said to abram because the iniquity
is not yet full of the land so god had
given them a 400 years of probationary
time before israel returned to the
promised land before the judgments came
upon them and they knew about abraham
and they were witnesses for the truth
during that time period
um but god was was giving them time to
make a decision
so it was unique situation yes
it was different from today all right
well thank you for your call israel you
know pastor i'm looking at the clock
we've got about a minute before we take
our break it probably wouldn't be fair
to take another call but friends if you
have a bible question we've got another
30 minutes that's going to be following
our break here uh taking your bible
questions the number to call is
800-463-7297
and if you don't get through right away
just stay on the line one of our call
screeners will contact or or talk to you
again the number is 800-463-7200
and uh
it's a good time now to call we'll get
your call on the program
you know might also be a good time to
mention that we have an important event
that's coming up in just a couple of
weeks we're going to be in las vegas
broadcasting a brand new series
called inspiration the bible's greatest
stories and i think they may even have
the information or slate they can put up
on the screen here for you that's going
to be
it's called
greateststories.org the series is called
inspiration the bible's greatest stories
you can watch on af tv
on the good news uh television 3abn
and facebook and youtube and hope you'll
go to that website invite your friends
to tune in we're coming back with more
bible questions in just a moment so
don't go away
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
the u.s government is drowning in debt
to the tune of 22 trillion dollars but
before you wag your finger at the
government spending the federal reserve
says the average american household
carries over a hundred and thirty seven
thousand dollars in debt well it was
never god's plan that we live with the
burden of debt proverbs 22 7 warns us
the rich rules over the poor and the
borrower is servant to the lender living
with debt is a stressful burden that
actually hurts your relationship with
god
in my new pocketbook deliverance from
debt i outline the bible principles on
how to properly manage your money with
some practical suggestions and how you
can get out and stay out of debt
if you or someone you love is drowning
in debt
order a copy of deliverance from debt
today it can be a lifesaver to keep you
from going under please call
800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
have you ever skipped a meal not a bad
idea if you need to watch your waistline
but there's a heavenly food you should
never skip god's word yet how can you
dive in daily when you're so busy
amazing facts has you covered and it's
as easy as signing up for our daily
devotional and verse of the day both
sent directly to your inbox ready to
bless inspire and inform you to start
receiving the amazing facts daily
devotional and verse of the day visit
amazingfacts.org and click on bible
study in the main menu you'll be glad
you did
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you
so what are you waiting for
get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today
[Music]
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live and those who have joined
us along the way this is a live
international interactive bible study
and you're invited to call in with your
bible questions and we're going to go
back to the phones right away my name is
doug batchelor my name is john ross and
pass today we'd like to just remind
folks that you might be listening to
this program on the radio because we
broadcast both on land base as well as
satellite radio but we also live
streaming on amazing facts uh facebook
page on the doug batchelor facebook page
i believe it's also on
the youtube channel amazing facts
youtube channel as well as on amazing
facts tv and good news tv so there's all
kinds of ways that you can stay in
contact with us and yeah let us know
that you're out there and if you have a
bible question we'd love to hear from
you next quarter that we have is
christine listening in florida christine
welcome to the program
hi pastor thank you for taking the call
it's just one one question how do we
submit our will to god how do we know
that we are actually doing
you know submitting our will to god
well that is the big question
uh the biggest battle that jesus fought
was there in the garden of gethsemane
where he said
you know father if there's any way for
this cup to pass from me
but not my will thy will be done and
that battle was so intense he prayed
that prayer three times and he was
perspiring blood
the bible describes it as an agony so
the biggest battle that any of us wage
and it's on a day-to-day basis is
saying not what i want lord but what you
want so how do you know if you're doing
that
uh well you um day by day ask yourself
am i doing my will or god's will god's
will is revealed in god's law
and in the teachings of jesus
and i think we do have a book that talks
about how can we know the will of god
and then there is a section on how do we
do the will of god
absolutely we'll be happy to send that
to anyone wanting to learn more about
knowing and doing the will of god it's
called how to determine the will of god
and the number to call for that is
800-835-6747
and we'll be happy to send you this free
book anywhere in north america again the
number is 800-835-6747
how to determine the will of god is the
name of the book so just ask for it
thanks for your call christine we got
teresa listening in washington d.c
theresa welcome to the program
hi good evening pastor evening
great i have a question uh regarding
revelation
uh chapter 16
verses one and two
where it states that the first vowel is
poured out upon the earth
and the men which had the mark of the
beast and
uh them which worship his image
if is that the close of probation
and the people that receive um this this
um
this mark the gr uh the grievous sword
will they have a chance to repent at
that time
uh no they
when the seven last plagues begin to
fall and they're in revelation chapter
16 you have the first
plagues and you've got first second
third plagues in the first four verses
there
um once the plagues begin to fall
probation is closed and pastor ross said
verse in revelation 22 where it says uh
he that is just let him be just still he
is filthy let him be filthy still it
kind of indicates that once you reach
the close of probation
the saved are saved the lost are lost
and there's the door of mercies closed
yeah you have revelation chapter 22
verse 11 where you have jesus saying he
that is let him be unjust still he that
is filthy let him be filthy still he
that is righteous let him be righteous
still he that is holy let him be holy
still and then the very next verse jesus
says behold i am coming quickly and my
reward is with me to give to every man
according to his work so the close of
probation precedes the second coming of
christ and once probation closes then
you have what the bible calls the wrath
of god which is the seven last plagues
that are poured out but god's people are
protected during that time of of plagues
some people ask well why does god send
the plagues if it's too late for people
to change sides well the plagues help to
reveal the heart of every person if you
read a little further in the plagues
instead of the wicked repenting when
they realize that these plagues are
coming because of their sins they harden
their hearts and they curse god for
sending the plagues yeah so it reveals
to the whole universe
that there's nothing more god can do to
try and save these people their hearts
are fully set towards evil yeah it says
when you come to the fourth plague and
men are scorched with great heat in
verse 9 that's revelation 16 verse 9
and it says they were scorched with
great heat and they blasphemed the name
of god who has power over the plagues
and they did not repent and give him
glory they didn't humble themselves they
blasphemed god they hardened their
hearts like pharaoh when the plagues
fell
and
yeah probations closed for them at this
time
all right well thanks for your call
teresa we've got bonita listening from
north carolina bonita welcome to the
program
thank you very much good evening evening
pastor doug and good evening pastor john
my question
i've been
trying to determine
what is the chronological order of when
lucifer got kicked out of heaven
why was he kicked out specifically and
when was he cast to
earth was it before or after the
creation of the world
all right well i think you're going to
find in
i think it's in ezekiel 28 where it says
you you have sinned
and therefore you were cast out so he
was cast out because of his rebellion
and his sin he wanted god's prese
position
so if you read in ezekiel 28
and read in isaiah 14 i think you'll
find there it
describes what the lucifer's goals were
and what his sins were why he was cast
out yeah with reference to the sequence
that you mentioned you find in
revelation chapter 12 it says there was
war in heaven
and the devil lost and he was cast out
he and his angels well this appears to
have happened before the creation of the
earth this rebellion or this war in
heaven once the earth was created then
of course lucifer had already been cast
out of heaven he was able to tempt adam
and eve and then he claimed the earth is
his because the loyalty that adam was to
give to god he now gave to the devil so
the devil claimed to be the
representative of the earth but we do
find another verse in revelation chapter
12 verse 12 it says therefore rejoice
our heavens and you that dwell in them
woe to the inhabitants of the earth for
the devil has come down to you having
great wrath because he knows he has a
short time and verse 11 says they
overcame them by the blood of the lamb
so at the cross the devil is cast down
again so he's cast out of heaven before
creation but at the cross he's cast down
in a sense meaning that he is isolated
to the earth because now jesus is the
rightful representative of those who put
their faith and trust in him so the
devil is cast out before creation he's
cast down in a sense at the cross and
that's revelation chapter
12 verse 10 that talks about salvation
has come and the devil has been cast
down
yes thank you bonita
next quarter that we have is carol
listening in new jersey carol welcome to
the program
hi good evening thank you so much for
taking my call pastor ross and pastor
john so my quick question is um
in in hebrews 11 verse 6
but without faith it is impossible to
please him for he that commit to god
must believe that he is and that he is a
reward of them that diligently seek him
so my question is
what is the difference between this
faith and presumptuous fate
because if you're if you're moving
according to
believing
um how can it hold can it reach to the
point where it becomes presumptuous
well that was really a good question
there is a difference between
having faith moving forward faith and
having a presumptuous faith
you know i'll give you just a quick
example
some pastors when they feel impressed
they're supposed to build a church
some will say let's start building
before we have the money
and other pastors will say that's
presumption
you should be you know raising some of
the money and so that you're not you
know starting a tower and you don't
finish and then there are other pastors
who say you ought to have all the money
before you start building
and so it's interesting to see these
different perspectives
you know i think sometimes if you find
yourself in dire straits you can believe
that god will save you but you don't
want to jump off a cliff or cast
yourself from the temple and say i've
got faith that angels are going to catch
me that's called presumption
so that's where you start tempting the
lord and saying that it's faith
uh so i don't know does it does that
make sense um carol
so if so if you move is it that is that
i understand that if you
if you put yourself in a position out of
the reach of the expectation of of what
you might do in opposing to what god
will do according to his will i'm
i'm i'm a little bit confused about that
well you know i yeah if you're spirit
led let me just say this when you're
baptized in the holy spirit sometimes
the holy spirit's going to ask you to do
really strange things
like you know he's going to ask you to
march around a city and blow a trumpet
and expect the walls to fall or he's
going to ask you to step off in the
jordan river when it's flooding and the
river will stop
so i i think i want to be clear that if
you look in the bible you're going to
see that people of faith are led by the
holy spirit to do things that may not
make any sense at all
and
and god bless us and when elijah prays
and fire comes down that took faith and
he prayed again it didn't rain
um then he prayed it did rain
so
uh but i think you know living day to
day you know we may not always feel the
holy spirit urging or guiding if you see
something in the word of god step out in
faith on what the word says regardless
of what you might see or feel
and god will bless your faith when it's
based on the word you know i've heard
one person put it this way they say do
what you know god wants you to do and
then leave the results with him
so every day you know try and do
everything we can in our power
to accomplish what we believe god is
wanting us to do and then leave the
results with him for example when jesus
fed the five thousand he asked well how
much food do you have well they had a
few loaves and fish and jesus took that
and then he multiplied and he fed more
than five thousand people so we are to
do what we can from a human perspective
and trust god
have faith in god that he will bring
about to pass what he has promised
that's right in other words somebody
says oh you know i want god to give me a
job
well if they're just going to be sitting
at home waiting for somebody to knock on
their door and offer them a job well
that's maybe presumption but if they're
out there doing the best they can and
they're looking for a job well then they
can trust that god will open and direct
them to the right place yeah it's not in
the bible but it is true that god helps
those that help themselves that's true
yeah
it's practical yeah well thanks for your
call carol rachel is listening in kansas
uh carol rachel welcome to the program
hi thank you for taking my call
i am i hope i can
ask this question correctly because i'm
not sure how to ask it but
um
i am reading the bible from
front to back and so i'm only in the old
testament
and god speaks words to moses and joshua
and
and he says fear not do not be afraid um
i'm with you be courageous
yes and
in today's time people like to share
scripture with you when whenever you're
having hardship or something
is there a scripture in the bible that
allows us to take those words that god
said to either moses or joshua or
whoever and actually use them in our
time
for us because they were spoken to
someone for certain situation
right yeah good question
um where is it pastor ross where peter
says
forgiven unto us our exceeding great and
precious promises that by these we might
become partakers of the divine nature
having escaped the corruption that is in
the world through lust
second peter chapter one verse four see
friends i'm dyslexic i remember the
verse i don't remember the verse father
i remember the the words
so he says there are promises given to
us in scripture that by these we might
become partakers of the divine nature so
when i read god and moses saying to
joshua be courageous be courageous be
very courageous and that's in i think
chapter one of joshua
i think i can apply that to me that god
is saying that if i'm willing to do his
will
i can be courageous and know that he's
with me
so the god has unchanged and so the same
promises and assurances that god gives
his prophets through history
they apply to me he also gave them
conditions so if we're following the
conditions that he gives them
we can claim the same promises that he
gives them and of course not only do we
have the examples in the old testament
where god says do not be afraid do not
fear but we find that repeated by jesus
and you do in the new testament where he
says don't be afraid don't worry about
what you're going to eat and what you're
going to wear god will take care of you
if you seek first the kingdom all these
things shall be added so those
principles that we see in the old
testament they repeat it in the new
testament that's right yeah without a
doubt very good all right next quarter
that we have is rob listening from
michigan rob welcome to the program
it's raj uh hi thank you
yes i i need you to elaborate on
daniel's vision where he saw this image
that symbolized
uh
several kingdoms starting with persian
media
uh
persia and it that it had brass it had
tin it had iron and
gold yeah and it
symbolizes the different civilizations
up to modern day so can you speak to
that a little bit more
sure and uh you know before i even get
into it i won't be able to cover it all
in just a few minutes but
uh we'll give you a free lesson
uh and it's called the millennial man
it's one of our historical lessons it's
the first one it's called the millennial
man it covers the prophecy of daniel
chapter 2
where nebuchadnezzar here's my quick
answer
has a dream of this large idol
and this huge image is made with a head
of gold the chest and arms are of silver
the belly is of bronze in the thighs the
legs are of iron the feet are iron and
clay and then he sees a stone cut
without hands come from the heavens
strike the image on the feet and it
basically pulverizes it and it all blows
away
that idol idol idolatry was forbidden by
the jewish people in the ten
commandments
it's forbidden for everybody represents
the religions of the world
and the head of gold daniel tells
nebuchadnezzar that's the kingdom of
babylon
the arms of silver were the kingdoms of
medo-persia
the bronze was the kingdom of greece
the iron was the kingdom of rome
the feet of iron and clay were the
division of the roman empire that went
with a combination of religion and
government and that's where you've got
the uh the papacy really ruling
uh the european civilization for over a
thousand years and it says in the days
of these kings that uh god is gonna
establish his kingdom we're living in
the toenails the very toes
of that image today
so take a look at that lesson anyone
could ask for that lesson on
the millennial man and it covers that
prophecy the number to call is
800-835-6747
and again you can ask for the study
guide actually one of the lessons called
uh millennial man it's part of the
historical set of lessons and we'll be
happy to send that to you thanks for
your call next quarter that we have is
aj listening from uh nebraska aj welcome
to the program
thanks for having me
um
my question is
why was michael punished for watching
david dance when he brought the ark into
the jerusalem
all right now michael i know it sounds
like a man's name but michael was the
wife of uh king david she was the
daughter of king saul david actually had
several wives
she wasn't punished for watching him
dance she was punished for mocking him
and it doesn't say david punished her it
basically says that
she never had children she was never
blessed with children and i think
another reason that michael never had
children is because
there were some people that wanted to
see the benjamites the descendants of
saul back on the throne and if god had
given
children to david through michael a lot
of people would say well naturally
it should be the children of david and
saul
as opposed to the children of david and
bathsheba and it ended up being solomon
the daughter or rather the son of
bathsheba so there were a couple of
reasons she shouldn't have been mocking
her husband for worshiping the lord
and
she did not like that he humbled himself
took off his robes and he was wearing
the simple linen ephod like a priest
good question thanks so much aj
we've got patrick listening also from
nebraska patrick welcome to the program
yes good evening pastor doug and pastor
ross um my question is concerning the
identity of machiavelli
he was both a king and a priest
i thought about this question when
someone asked a question concerning noah
and the tower of babel
the identity of mechezadek if pastor uh
ambassador if you could
elaborate on that some i'd appreciate it
thank you
yeah you know well we know that
melchizedek is a type of christ because
here abraham coming back from the battle
with the kings of the north
melchizedek who is the
king and priest of salem later known as
jerusalem same place
abraham pays tithe to him
so he's someone who seems to be a
worshiper of the true god it says he's
the priest of the most high god
and you think what's he doing in canaan
somebody that worships the true god
some have speculated and you can't
really prove it but it is a workable
theory
that
one of the sons of noah who was still
alive hashem lived over 600 years
his life overlapped with the life of
abraham over a hundred years
i think 170 years
and so
some have said well after abraham moved
because of thy idolatry that was in er
that hashem may have also heard that god
had led abraham to this promised land
and he had come with his clan and
settled there we don't know that it's
just one theory and
he appears mysteriously out of nowhere
the bible doesn't say who his people are
where he came from where he went to so
he's sort of a type of christ in that
he's without beginning or end biblically
he just appears and disappears now if
you read from the book of hebrews paul
does spend quite a bit of time talking
about melchizedek as a type of christ
he was both a priest and a king
and apparently abraham recognized this
because abraham the great patriarch he
gave a tithe to melchizedek
and that's a little different the levi's
came through the the seed of abraham but
here is melchizedek of a different type
of priesthood and paul says that's the
type of priesthood of jesus
all right great question thank you carol
is listening california carol welcome to
the program
hi thank you for taking my call yes
in revelation
some things are literal and some things
are symbolic
and
in regards to the hundred and forty four
thousand people that will
will be uh alive when jesus comes
um how is that interpreted
well the 144 000 you find them mentioned
in revelation 7 and then double that you
find them mentioned in revelation 14.
the 144 thousand um they are not the
only ones saved i do believe the number
is literal but i think this is a number
that is basically describing the last
day apostles around the world
you know jesus had 12 apostles that
prepared
the people of israel for his first
coming
and introduced him at pentecost
and then before his second coming he'll
have 12 times 12 000
both literal literal and spiritual jews
and so um
i think that you know calling them
children of israel that's symbolic
because those that are christ are
abraham's seed god is not going to be
raising up twelve thousand from the
tribe of gad
or manasseh they don't exist anymore
they intermarried before jesus was born
and disappeared
so it's basically saying that god's
gonna have these last day people filled
with the spirit doing a work similar to
the work of the apostles preparing a
great multitude for jesus coming now we
have a book on this we'll be happy to
send you a free copy carol yes the book
is called who will sing the song
understanding the hundred and forty four
thousand a book written by pastor doug
and we'll be happy to send this to you
carol or anyone who calls and asks the
number is 800-835-6747
just ask for the book on the 144 000
it's called who will sing the song
we'll get that in the mail and send it
to you
uh next caller that we have let's see
we've got uh
elisa
elisa listening from michigan lisa
welcome to the
program hi
thank you for taking my call
um my question
well
i know that it's best um with prophecy
unfolding like it is to be out of the
cities and into the country and
my family i have two severe autistic
boys and we do plan on moving to the
country but my question is in the time
of
where we can't buy or sell and the blue
laws are there
how are we
going to live because we may have a
mortgage and probably land taxes if we
don't have a mortgage so i was just
wondering how that would work because
we'll have you know that home in the
country but still
we won't be able to buy or sell so that
is what i'm wondering about good
question um
you know i think the last thing to
happen would be
that banks will not take your money
when you when you can't buy something
that's different but if you're trying to
pay
uh pay someone back
for um a property or a mortgage they'll
probably accept payment
but it's going to be hard for people to
buy now when it says they can't buy or
sell not only will that be happening on
a personal level that's already
happening it's in the news today on an
international level they call it
economic sanctions when one nation tells
another nation we are not going to allow
you to buy it's been in the news a lot
lately with russia and some of those
sanctions
so
you know i think that's the bigger part
of what's happening in revelation is
that the united states and other nations
are going to punish
parts of the world that don't go along
with religious laws but it's also going
to happen
on an individual basis and it'll be very
easy to control i mean even now you know
we've seen that with covid there's been
a lot of government involvement in
personal things travel and purchases
can't go to certain stores so it's very
easy to see with electronic money how
quickly this could happen
hope that helps elisa pastor ross i see
we've got two minutes left let me just
share a couple things with our friends
we may have time for one more question
but i want to squeeze this in if you
didn't hear at halftime we shared an
announcement in two weeks pastor ross
and i are going to be
we're going to vegas
but we're going to las vegas we're going
to be at the paradise church that sounds
suspicious already doesn't it honest
friends it's a church and we're going to
be sharing a brand new series it's
called inspiration the bible's greatest
stories you
can be part of it we want you to come if
you can't come in person and you'll find
the information about where we are
physically you can come by watching you
can watch right here on af tv better
life television three angels
broadcasting
youtube facebook
and i'm sure i'm leaving something out
but go to that website called
www.greateststories.org
and you can get the information you can
also just go to the amazing facts
website and you'll find more information
there on inspirations the bible's
greatest stories it's going to be ten
presentations on some of the great
stories in the bible how they teach us
the bible truth and also how to
experience revival in your life we we
all want that uh you know one more thing
i thought i'd share is
when we prepare to sign off it's kind of
like saying goodnight to people that
have come to visit at uh dinner party we
do it in stages
and first we will be signing off with
our national satellite channel that is
carrying a bible answers live but don't
go away because we come right back for
all those that are listening online or
the land-based stations and we will be
taking a rapid fire series of questions
for two minutes pastor ross if someone
wants to send us not everyone can call
in or not everyone wants to get on the
radio and call in with a question if
they want to email us questions for the
rapid fire what's the address for that
the address is just simply bal questions
that at
amazingfacts.org again that's bal bible
answers live questions at
amazingfacts.org
if you're watching this on social media
you can actually type your question
there in the comment section
and we'll try to gather those questions
together put them
down and try to answer as many of them
as we can during our special two-minute
segment that's going to be coming up in
like 10 seconds from now pastor doug
that's right and also don't forget check
out everything else that's available
through the ministry at amazingfacts.org
we'll be back in just a few moments for
our other audience
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international a
faith-based ministry located in granite
bay california
hello friends welcome back we have about
two minutes past the night to answer
some of the questions that have been
sent into the program we've got some
great questions this evening i'm curious
about the answer so let's get started
first question that we have is is there
a biblical example of when you have to
love your enemy
yeah i think there's probably several
examples you've got the example in the
bible where king david had an
opportunity to get vengeance on king
saul saul was actually hunting david to
kill him and on two occasions david
just providentially
basically had an opportunity to pin saul
to the ground or to kill him and he said
i won't do it and he let him go free and
even told saul he said look i can kill
you right now but i'm going to let you
go free
okay he loved his enemy elisha
forgave a whole army that was trying to
capture him and said feed them and send
them home
all right very good another question we
have what does it mean to love the lord
with all of your heart and all of your
soul
well you know jesus said if you love me
keep my commandments and when we love
the lord with all of our heart and all
our soul makes me think of that that
statement you find in deuteronomy
chapter 5 i think it's verse 29 where he
said oh that all of my people would love
me and keep all of my commandments
always that it might be well with them
and their children
and so we show that we love the lord
with all of our heart by doing all that
we know he wants us to do
okay another question that we have can
our dead family members hear us speak to
them
do they know what's happening with us
here on earth
the bible tells us in the book of isaiah
that we are not to console the wizards
that mutter and peep in the dark and
that's in isaiah chapter 8.
i think if you read 18 19 20
should the living go to the dead for
knowledge
the bible tells us that in the last days
the wicked will be
there are devils working miracles you
read in revelation 16. satan can be
transformed into an angel of light he
can impersonate the spirits of the dead
as happened with the witch of endor
the living know that will die the dead
don't know anything they do not return
to their house job 14 tells us and haunt
the house
okay another question that we have is
how long does it take to be right with
god after repenting of sin
well that's good news the bible says
that as soon as we repent
he immediately forgives you see this
where the thief on the cross said lord
remember me
right away jesus promised you will be
with me in paradise
when zacchaeus came to christ jesus
declared this is a son of abraham
when isaiah said i am a sinful man god
cleansed him and said your sin is purged
so as soon as we repent he forgives
that's the good news that is absolutely
again thank you friends for your bible
questions if we didn't get to your
question this evening make sure you join
us next week as we try to answer more
bible questions
you